mon chien finale à 140
ce langage codé des ventes aux enchères
parle à tous pourtant ce monde et ses
acteurs restent méconnus on n'imagine
pas forcément mais avant une vente aux
enchères un long et rigoureux travail
attend le maître de cérémonie
le commissaire priseur chaque lot est
décrit avec une grande précaution
photographié est estimée et authentifié
puisque on est là aussi pour pour dire
que l'objet est bien d'époque que ce
n'est pas une copie dans cet hôtel des
ventes de dijon des centaines d'ouvragés
d'exception sont mises aux enchères
l'âge la rareté l'état la reliure sont
autant de critères pour évaluer le prix
d'un livre
le commissaire priseur plus généraliste
a dû faire appel à un expert
l'intérêt c'est de trouver quelque chose
qu'on n'a jamais vues qui est pas trop
répertoriés et donc ça demande beaucoup
de travail et c'est enrichissant dans
les deux sens d'ailleurs plus terre mais
les ventes aux enchères ont du mal à se
démocratiser
entrée dans cette salle reste la sphère
d'un public averti ou déformant donc je
viens de cinq ans encore mais
aujourd'hui vont pas très simple je suis
marchand de livres et pour en acheter en
vente
il faut bien que jean mach est que je
suis je vais très souvent dans l'essonne
des monte entre dijon et lyon
d'ailleurs le marché du livre reste très
accessible
ce passionné a pu remplir son coffre
d'une centaine d'ouvragés pour une
trentaine d'euros